bueno
[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a diario de copas el espacio
de france 24 en donde analizamos la
actualidad de la eurocopa la copa
américa y todo lo relacionado con estos
torneos a continuación los titulares
golpe de autoridad la selección de
alemania se impuso con marcador de 4
goles por 2 a portugal y sumó sus
primeros tres puntos en el torneo
europeo tras la derrota los lusos se
jugarán el pase a la siguiente ronda el
próximo miércoles ante la selección de
francia tenemos análisis
preocupación en españa la selección que
dirige luis enrique empató a un gol
frente a polonia y marcha tercera en el
grupo e que lidera suecia su próximo
partido será ante eslovaquia tante se
jugarán el pase a la siguiente fase
tenemos análisis
acción en la copa américa venezuela
alista sus baterías para enfrentar a
ecuador en la tercera fecha del grupo b
con otro duelo colombia tratará de
borrar el empate frente a la vinotinto
cuando se mida a perú que quiere olvidar
su derrota ante brasil analizamos la
previa
gracias por estar con nosotros para
analizar y conocer detalles de los dos
torneos prestigiosos a nivel de
selecciones después de la copa del mundo
hoy al igual que todas las emisiones
anteriores tenemos el placer de contar
con la compañía de sara castro directora
del diario 'as' colombia bienvenida sara
hoy lo hizo un gusto hemos visto muy
buenos partidos y buenas propuestas
futbolísticas en esta eurocopa que ya
vamos a analizar cada uno de esos
partidos porque para entrar en materia
el grupo f se puso emocionante el empate
de francia ante hungría a un gol y la
victoria de alemania sobre portugal 4
por 2 dejaron completamente abierto este
grupo y cualquier cosa puede pasar
sara se sabía que portugal no era
favorita para escalar en alemania pero
un resultado de esta magnitud
más allá de los autogoles significa un
golpe de mesa para la selección alemana
empecemos hablando eso de alemania yo
creo que desde el posicionamiento se
bebió un equipo mucho más agresivo y
mucho más inteligente para hacer daño en
el área rival
y me fue fundamental y por supuesto la
figura del partido go sense que no sólo
por el gol sino por toda la construcción
y el daño que le hizo a la defensa de
portugal fue muy interesante luego yo
creo que hay un capítulo aparte para
cristiano ronaldo completo 107 goles con
la selección de portugal y recorrió 97
metros en 14 segundos en ese primer gol
para alemán y creo que es uno de los
goles más interesantes y más bonitos
construidos en este en este campeonato
porque es una transición ofensiva como
bajo todos los cánones entonces creo que
vamos a ver una definición muy
interesante entre francia y portugal
pero lo que dices es de lo que se trata
es que no es como empieza sino como la
jerarquía de un equipo como alemania se
va trasladando a través del torneo en
resultados y por supuesto que pueda
llegar incluso a pelear por llegar a la
final
vamos precisamente ahora a escuchar lo
que dijo el técnico alemán tras concluir
este partido tengas guadix
creo que fue un partido muy fuerte de
nuestra parte contra portugal que por
supuesto fueron técnicamente fuertes y
contra atacantes con 2
y mostramos mucha moral hoy
especialmente después de estar abajo en
el marcador pero exhibimos un espíritu
realmente bueno no perdimos la
compostura después del 0 a 1 y también
logramos mantener el impulso en este
juego y en mid en sahagún following como
ya lo habíamos adelantado francia empató
a un gol ante la selección de hungría
gracias a la anotación de antoine
griezmann en la segunda parte escuchemos
lo que dijo el jugador sobre lo que será
la próxima presentación del conjunto
francés
vamos a tener que trabajar el partido
tácticamente para ver cómo podemos
hacerles daño y jugar para ganar no será
fácil
ya lo sabemos pero hay que hacerlo para
lograr los tres puntos y la primera
plaza del grupo por boleto a paella de
excepto de comerlas en otro duelo de la
jornada de españa pacto a un gol frente
a la selección de polonia un resultado
que les complica en sus aspiraciones de
avanzar mejor posicionados para la
siguiente fase escuchemos lo que dijo el
técnico español sobre él
próximo partido que enfrentarán ante
eslovaquia
ya llegamos a la prueba definitiva el
tercer partido será un match match ball
y ese es el partido hay que ganar si
queremos
y pasar a la siguiente fase y además con
una peculiaridad que se cualquiera de
los cuatro equipos del grupo depende de
sí mismo
saber qué está pasando con esta
selección de españa que le está costando
ganar partidos y precisamente ante
rivales que se ven más débiles en el
papel si un partido muy difícil para
hacer la selección española porque en el
primero parecía que sólo había faltado
el gol en éste faltaron muchas cosas es
una selección débil en las dos áreas no
define pero tampoco defiende bien y eso
lo dejó muy a la vista polonia yo creo
que desde el colectivo no logra verse un
equipo que logre dominar en los momentos
del partido y eso le va a costar mucho
el técnico dijo luis enrique dijo antes
del partido que eran morata y diez más y
creo que más allá del gol de morata le
faltan muchas otras piezas para lograr
eso ver un equipo con ímpetu y sobre
todo con esa capacidad de lograr
clasificarse haber sería realmente
catastrófico que de 24 equipos
clasifique en 16 y ahí no está españa
compitiendo bueno ya lo explicó el se
juegan una final ante eslovaquia y no
era lo esperado seguro que sí partidos
sumamente interesantes pero ya entramos
precisamente en esos
la fecha de cada uno de los grupos y a
esta hora están en acción dos equipos
del grupo a juega italia frente a gales
y suiza hace lo propio frente a turquía
dos equipos que están necesitados de una
victoria para pensar en la siguiente
fase pero pasamos las notas de la copa
américa que también tendrá acción el día
de hoy y en donde la jornada contempla
el duelo entre la representación de
venezuela que estará midiéndose a
ecuador más adelante colombia enfrentará
a la representación de perú pero
empecemos por analizar este último
partido sobre todo el de colombia hay
mucha expectativa en lo que podría pasar
con colombia con perú dos equipos que
están urgidos por decirlo de alguna
manera de mejorar su actuación en la en
la copa pero que realmente podemos
esperar de un partido que se ve en el
papel tan complejo reinaldo rueda sigue
poniendo a prueba su trabajo ya lleva
cuatro partidos al frente de la
selección colombia y se le ha visto
cosas positivas al equipo es un equipo
mucho más libre técnicamente pero le
falta aceitar algunos
en lo colectivo y luego recargar el que
llega con toda la presión hizo un muy
buen primer tiempo ante brasil
presionó intentó tener la pelota pero no
fue suficiente viene con malos
resultados de la eliminatoria ayer
conversamos de hecho en rueda de prensa
con reinaldo rueda sobre la necesidad de
no depender tanto del juego por bandas
con juan guillermo cuadrado sino
intentar generar juego interior yo creo
que ahí va a estar como esa evolución
ofensiva de la selección de colombia es
un partido interesante un partido que
además empieza ya a definir los
clasificados a los cuartos de final y
creo que son dos selecciones que ya
desde en los últimos tiempos han
mostrado muy buenos partidos trabuco
vuelve a la selección de perú y eso va a
ser importante porque es un hombre con
salida que sin duda le aporta mucho al
ataque de la selección peruana ayer
precisamente ambos seleccionadores
ofrecieron sus declaraciones previo a
este partido y escuchemos lo que dijo
cada uno de ellos
somos conscientes que quizás juan
guillermo ocupa una posición donde
quizás no está tan expuesto
quizás más dispuesto pueden estar los
rivales
y que tienen que controlar esa zona de
cuadrado
y así de otros jugadores nuestros que
también
pueden en cualquier momento acumular
pero lo inicial ahora es enfrentar a
perú con toda la focalización en el
juego en trabajar esos 95 minutos 97
minutos bueno es una selección que es
difícil de enfrentar como volvemos a
reiterar como lo es colombia de hace
tiempo no sea colombia ha crecido
muchísimo con el correr de los años así
que bueno no es algo que en la cual
nosotros podamos descubrir ahora es
cierto o sea nos ha tocado partidos
definitorio por ejemplo que ni más ni
menos
definir una entrada mundial
entonces sabemos los partidos que hemos
enfrentado con ellos que son difíciles
independientemente del momento
la jornada se abre con el choque entre
la selección de venezuela que ayer sumó
una nueva baja tras la lesión del ángel
herrera y estará enfrentando a ecuador
sara dos equipos que llegan con
realidades completamente distintas
sabemos los problemas de venezuela pero
ecuador quiere hacer parte de esta copa
para nosotros ya es claro lo que va a
intentar hacer peseiro en este partido
mantener un bloque muy junto pero el
equipo de alfaro mostró sobre todo en el
partido ante colombia una una imponencia
ofensiva es decir ellos desde el físico
y desde su capacidad ofensiva iban a
intentar meter al equipo de peseiro muy
en su área ahora lo que tienen es que
cuidar mucho los retrocesos defensivos
si ellos dejan mucho espacio a la
espalda incluso un equipo con venezuela-
con pocas fichas y como lo están jugando
este torneo creo que podría tener
posibilidades ahí se juega casi que el
eliminado del grupo o sea y ya se pasa a
otro a otro objetivo la dignidad de este
equipo la vamos a reiterar siempre del
equipo de venezuela pero creo que
ecuador por lo visto en eliminatoria
y por lo visto en este partido ante
colombia tiene armas para lograr esos
tres puntos que lo empiezan a hacer
soñar también con esta clasificación a
continuación
escuchemos una selección de noticias
relacionadas con estos dos torneos
ahora después de haber sido declarado
jugador del barcelona de españa el
neerlandés memphis depay ofreció sus
primeras impresiones como jugador
blaugrana el jugador llega procedente de
lyon francés que era una de las
pretensiones de ronald koeman para la
próxima campaña
la selección de brasil que hoy cumple
jornada de descanso ya empieza a
trabajar en su próximo partido de la
copa américa donde rivalizará frente a
colombia
los dirigidos por ti te suman 6 puntos
en dos presentaciones y marchan líderes
del grupo b
la llegada de brighton al seleccionado
de chile no sólo ha causado un impacto
entre los aficionados de ese país sino
que le ha servido en lo personal para
mejorar su valor de mercado de acuerdo
con el portal especializado
transfermarkt es nacido en reino unido-
y de madre chilena subió tube su
tasación 25 por ciento durante la copa
en esta manera llegamos al final de la
presente emisión de diarios de copas
muchas gracias a todos por estar con
nosotros y sigan con más de la
programación de france 24 y france 24
puntocom